[Music]
big black engine coming through Josh
I've started an amateur drama club at
lunchtime well there's four of us so
it's not it's not big but still
why are you asking me I just thought it
might be something you'd enjoy five
things five things five things five
things
bread yes
I think you should coach the team
oh homo was that a question or a
statement what you know was it a
question like am I a home mobile was it
a statement like you're over
Performing Arts sounds like a secure
career move
Madigan says I'm a good actor oh does he
and you are not crap Josh
well any behavior that threatens our
ideal will not be tolerated
pram charm
more of a sitter
you can't be looked at out here is the
real world it's different so you've got
to be different
I didn't know all that about your people
darling they're your people too
you know how to wipe that thing uh yeah
I think so
to disobey my instructions you nearly
sabotage everything we want protesting
they told you
you don't know what it feels like
to not fit in
yeah it's hard and you can't do anything
that makes you you got one job love you
do whatever I need you to do to keep
this family together
[Music]
we have the whole world watching us
right now and we can't waste this moment
Josh is a really tricky kid to get to
know it's when he's performing that we
get the best
[Music]
we all have our stories they're not
there to pull us down
the leader push us forward
[Applause]
you know this way is faster right I
think I've ruptured my gluteus maximus
it is impossible to Rapture your ass
[Music]
foreign